bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soit comment sortir de
l'impasse parlementaire emmanuel macron
a reçu les chefs de partis politiques à
l'elysée aujourd'hui composé oui mais
avec qui les républicains lui ont dit
non françois bayrou prône l'union
nationale et voir philippe une coalition
macron à la recherche de la majorité
perdue c'est notre grand débat ce soir
notre grand témoin était en bonne place
ce matin sur la photo de famille des 131
députés de la nuque qui ont fait leur
entrée en fanfare au palais bourbon elle
fait partie des 4 et les filles élu dès
le premier tour dimanche dernier elle
est l'architecte de la stratégie de jean
luc mélenchon au coeur de son premier
cercle le soft est chic et vous êtes
avec nous ce soir enfin nous
retrouverons nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris le regard de jean rémi godeau
sur la mort du front républicain en fin
de vie de shell va nous dire pourquoi la
présidence de la commission des finances
et si convoité à l'assemblée puis
richard v relie la france à gouvernable
veut d'étrangers voilà pour le menu
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs
44 c'est le nombre de députés que doit
convaincre l'exécutif sur chaque texte
pour éviter la paralysie à l'assemblée
nationale après une journée de
consultation elle est l'idée c'est
l'impasse toujours ce soir alors peut-on
en sortir et si oui comment bonsoir
patrick vignal un choix merci d'être
avec nous réélu député et la république
en marche de l'hérault circonscription
plutôt marquée à gauche vous êtes ancien
socialiste je le précise parce que vous
ça permet de situer d'un an dans la
république en marche dans le parti
présidentiel puisque j'ai envie de dire
voilà dans cette période de confusion
mieux vaut dire les choses bonsoir
stéphane peu bonjour bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous aux députés de la nuque
réélu député de seine-saint-denis
députés communistes et bonsoir géraldine
géraldine muhlmann cette politologue
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université panthéon assas
on a plein de questions à vous poser ce
soir parce que la situation est confuse
pierre henri dumont députée les
républicains la droite pourrait être le
pivot d'une coalition d'impact on ne
sait pas quel mot choisir il est réélu
député les républicains du pas-de-calais
on va poser les faits rien que les faits
d'abord main avec vous montez par
stéphane bonsoir myriam bonsoir à toutes
et tous à j + 2 des chocs électorale est
ce que le brouillard se dissipe un peu
si j'ai bien compris la miba kof qui
tout de suite
[Musique]
alors ça consulter à l'elysée si j'ai
bien compris ce soir ah oui puisqu'on a
réélu un président mais sans lui donner
de majorité absolue donc on se demande
mais comment va-t-il faire pour
gouverner et encore moi je m'interroge
pourra-t-il gouverner point
d'interrogation de la une du parisien
hier lundi c'était ingouvernable point
d'exclamation il se posait même pas la
question s'était retranché derrière
elisabeth borna de donner sa démission
dès ce matin au président alors c'était
une des missions de courtoisie et le
président l'a refusée lui est bon dans
le temps il n'avait pas du tout le choix
parce que j'imagine qu'il accepte cette
décision alors qu'est ce qui va faire
reconduire elisabeth bande pourquoi pas
mais nommée quel ministre dans cette
situation
non franchement il n'y a pas grand chose
à faire à part montrer cet après midi qu
il habite bornes étaient au travail tu
pas en conseil des ministres un
président n'est pas là lui consulte mais
avec d'autres ministres qui sont chacun
passé devant le micro en disant on
travaille très dur sur toutes les lois
seront pouvoir d'achat donc le
gouvernement travaille mais que fait le
président en lui alors justement le
président consultait qu'ont dit les
chefs de partis à la sortie de ces
entretiens présidentielle l'impression
des gens ils se font un peu ennuyé en
attendant chaque chef de parti sortir
parce qu'ils n'ont rien dit qu'il
n'avait déjà dit dès le soir du premier
tour par grant côté l'air bon bah voilà
pas de surprise on sait qu'il ya de
nombreux ministres de droite au
gouvernement on se fait ch lagarde il ya
des gens comme copé ou catherine vautrin
qui plaide pour un pacte de gouvernement
mais la position officielle c'est
christian jacob en tant que président
qu'il l'a rappelé ce matin devant des
journalistes j'ai redit au président que
n'était pas question pour pour nous de
rentrer dans ce qui pourrait être
considéré comme trahison de nos
électeurs donc nous avons fait une
campagne dans l'opposition à sa majorité
dans l'opposition à son gouvernement
nous restons dans une position dents
dans l'opposition de manière déterminée
déterminé mais mais responsables jamais
on ne sera dans le blocage des
institutions à tout prix garder hilali
jamais il ne sera dans le blocage mais
alors pas dire que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour le président un mâcon
parce que ce moment à parler de bonne
nouvelle ça prendrait un tour ironique
mais ça veut dire que christian jacob
n'exclut pas de voter certaines réformes
comme celle des retraites un exemple il
veut bien la beauté si on monte un peu
le montant des pensions et surtout si on
allonge allonger la durée de cotisation
enfin bon ce que c'est vraiment la
priorité pour le président mâcon
d'attaqués sur les retraites alors ça
veut dire que au cas par cas texte après
texte on peut trouver une majorité c'est
jouable ça coûtait mais pourquoi pas dès
ce matin olivier faure est arrivé et il
a dit oui mais alors moi je suis tout à
fait prêt à négocier nous on fixe le
salaire minimum à 1500 euros mais si à
l'issue des négociations annuelles de
macron tombent d'accord sont 1480 on va
le soutenir voyez donc fait que c'est
quand même un petit peu d'ironie de la
part d'olivier fort beaucoup plus que
chez les filles là où on ironise moi on
n'est plus ce premier degré où on a une
grosse envie de bloquer et en tout cas
de renverser le gouvernement
bon c'est sûr que voilà ce qu'on attend
maintenant du gouvernement sous ces
latitudes de macron est-ce qu'elle va
changer et olivier faure en parler on a
eu une période dite jupitérienne où le
président décider seul et où il n'avait
de comptes à rendre à personne désormais
parce qu'il n'a pas de majorité eh bien
il est contraint à une re
parlementarisation de la vie politique
et c'est plutôt sain dans un pays comme
le nôtre d'avoir en fait à rendre des
comptes d'avoir à négocier à chercher
des points d'accord qui permettent
d'avancer dans le bon sens les marine le
pen alors marine le pen elle aussi rien
de très très très nouveau puisque elle
revendique son rôle de premier reposante
l assise sur l'immigration sur la
sécurité sur le pouvoir d'achat qui bien
sûr elle cite toujours en premier mais
enfin on peut noter que le rn non plus
mais pas décidés à s'opposer à toute
mesure que propres gouvernements
écoutent et jordan dare della sera une
opposition ferme responsable
républicaine qui accompagnera des
mesures d'urgence il doit y en avoir et
je pense notamment à
l'indexation des pensions de retraite
sur l'inflation qu'on a réclamé depuis
le début de cette campagne
présidentielle donc bref si on résume à
part les insoumis qui ont l'air de
vouloir un qui disent d'ailleurs qui
veulent changer les institutions et qui
ont cru qu on dire non à tout en faisant
un maximum de bruit tous les autres
disent baffe pourquoi pas s'il ya des
mesures qui vont dans notre sens nous on
est prêts à voter certains textes du
gouvernement donc a priori il ya comme
un léger chemin pour en théorie réussir
à trouver une majorité au cas par cas et
les théories maintenant est-ce qu en
pratique c'est possible il ya des balles
justement on va commencer ce débat avec
vous patrick vignal est ce que il y a
une voie possible déjà quels mots vous
mettriez sur la situation politique
personne ne l'avait anticipé
est-ce que dire qu'on est voilà dans une
france ingouvernable à ce stade on a
quand même trois ministres qui ne sont
pas remplacés une première ministre dont
on ne connaît pas encore vraiment le
sort puisqu'il ya un remaniement qui a
tendu un conseil des ministres annulaire
conseil de national de la refondation
reporter qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
comment vous appréhendez la situation
quand je vois tout ça je comprends
pourquoi 50 % des français ne sont pas
allés voter parce que là on parle pas
des français on parle de la tambouille
politique alors on va assumer les choses
nous n'avons pas eu la majorité nous
n'avons pas été très bons est ce que
c'est la faute du président de la
première ministre de nous les
parlementaires us qu'il ya beaucoup de
sang et sur le chaos mais soyons sérieux
franchement où on est aujourd'hui moi
j'ai eu la chance de faire un mandat
2012 2017 avec olivier faure et olivier
nous disait il faut que les banques
centrales aient tous voter tous parce
que en une majorité est aujourd'hui le
même olivier m'explique que il faut
qu'il y ait plus d'émoi sens voter sur
françois hollande il y avait les
frondeurs 1 vous ne visez pas à l'époque
je vibre aux différentes ici et moi
j'étais déjà jeté pas frondeurs mais je
disais les choses 2017 c'est pareil
jusqu'à maintenant on va le dire je
pense qu'un pansement collecte c'était
plus ou moins une chambre
d'enregistrement
il va y avoir une vraie démocratie j'ai
pas tout suivi
la chambre d'enregistrement vous trouvez
que c'est plus valorisant par le mode
être seulement les 100 bougies c'est
devenir madame ce que je peux maintenant
à majorité est justement en été avec une
majorité ont voté moi ça me dérange pas
qu'une vraie démocratie et qu'on est en
et débloque le problème que vous avez
aujourd'hui c'était bien dit elle est si
une partie des les fier parce que les
socialiser clos sont pas d'accord veut
renverser la table mais linchamps le
deal assume je prends lui veut le chaos
- madame les 10 millions de personnes
qui aient moins de 1000 euros la petite
dame qui mec qui ce matin qui dort dans
sa voiture et trois gosses elle s'en
fout de nos problèmes
vous voulez dire que c'est une
opportunité politique qu'il faut
s'interdire depuis la majorité vous
dites je pense que oui on a ou la
bouteille à moitié vide ou à moitié ne
soyons pas dans le repli nous devons
aller convaincre alors j'irai pas juste
une robe de mariée pour mes deux
collègues pour leur dire venez pour
qu'il faut voter pour moi elle est mais
je vais m'asseoir majeur pense qu'il
faut trouver une nouvelle forme de
démocratie
nous devons maintenant convaincre les
gens du parlement pour servir les
français qui attendent ces bons soirs
tambouille politique alors ça c'est
madame mais non c'était le cas le
président de mandature on avait la
majorité on était 340 c'était trop oui
et bien c'est bien que ça bouleverse
félicite finale choisir mullen bonsoir
terre aurait du monde ce soir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député les
républicains vont aussi réélu dans le
nord pas de calais sq alors c'est
toujours l'impasse ce soir la faute à
qui à la faute et en premier lieu
à emmanuel macron pardon de le dire mais
c'est quand même lui qui a comme
personne auparavant ont fait monter les
extrêmes et faire rentrer les populisme
d'extrême gauche et d'extrême droite au
sein de l'assemblée nationale c'est lui
qui a quand même réussi le tour de force
incroyable d'avoir avec les institutions
de la vème république créer une forme de
nouvelles quatrième république et donc
nous les députés les républicains on l'a
toujours dit nous serons dans une
opposition ferme une opposition qui sera
une opposition aussi responsable est-ce
qu'on peut essayer de donner des
exemples concrets il ya un texte pouvoir
d'achat qui arrive c'est l'urgence
absolue des français lui un accord en
juillet une fois que l'assemblée
nationale sera définitivement installé
ça veut dire quoi concrètement le chèque
alimentaire votez pour nous un deck
c'est selon sur les retraites ne va pas
se poser là pour ça va pas se passer
comme ça
ça passe possible donc s'amuser gel du
point d'indicé va se passer pouvoir sont
contre différentes à savoir que nous
députés les républicains nous allons
présenter avant même chaque projet de
loi nos propositions et nous allons dire
sur le pouvoir d'achat nous allons
rappeler notre programme le programme
c'était quoi c'était baisse' baisser les
taxes sur l'essence pour les arrive pour
arriver à un litre à 1 euro 5 ans sur
l'essence et sur le diesel nous allons
dire sur le pouvoir d'achat toujours
qu'il faut faire en sorte que le travail
paye mieux et donc il fallait déjà des
baisses de taxes sur l'essence
absolument séparer de réseautage et une
remise enfin tout cas ça fait tâche a
donc nous ce que nous disons non mais
bon mes trucs là c'est très clair de 50
mots clés de votre programme notre
programme le pouvoir d'achat mesure les
mesures gens répètent les mesures on a
eu cette mesure sur le litre d'essence
qui est extrêmement forte on a une
mesure sur le fait que le travail paye
mieux qu'ils ne payent aujourd'hui une
défiscalisation totale des heures
supplémentaires une possibilité de
convertir des rtt en salaire va les
propositions très claires et après ce
sera la majorité de nous dire sur notre
position est-ce qu'on sauve les relais
de donnant donnant est ce que si le
gouvernement sur le résidentiel reprend
un certain nombre de mesures de lettres
des biens pourrions l'ensemble du paquet
puisque ce sont non pouvoir d'achat pour
être vrai nous pourrions vrai dilemme
pour être bien clair mais c'est à dire
que le parti le parti présidentiel la
majorité doit faire quelque chose de
nouveau pour les députés de la majorité
c'est à dire écoutez les oppositions
pendant cinq ans ils ont été obtenues
obstiné à ne pas vouloir écouter les
oppositions dans l'intérieur même du
règlement intérieur du groupe la
république en marche il y avait
interdiction pour les députés de la
république en marche de voter ou de co
signé des amendements déposés par les
oppositions et c'est ça aussi qui a créé
ce chaos on avait les français avaient
l'impression que l'assemblée nationale
qui était pourtant censé être
l'assemblée du renouvellement est lui en
2017 était une assemblée en réalité de
notables qui faisait que suivre les
ordres du gouvernement qui n'avait pas
une capacité par elle même de pouvoir
légiférer sur les problèmes réels des
français ses frères je garde en mémoire
un exemple très clair celui de
l'allocation d'adulte handicapé qui a
été portée cher qu un peu on sait à la
fois par la droite aurait égaré
par stéphane poste pour ce faire je fais
la chance et vous rendez bien compte que
pendant cinq ans ils ont refusé trois
fois ils l'ont refusée la majorité vous
faites le match eh bien on fait le bilan
mais maintenant on se projette on se
projette moi je voudrais savoir aussi
est très rapidement si elisabeth bornes
fait une déclaration de politique
générale le 4 juillet et si elle demande
la confiance qu'est ce que vous faites
pour ça allait mal se présente très bien
que elisabeth bornes aujourd'hui elle
est maintenue à son poste pour pas
ajouter de la crise à la crise et que
normalement en toute cohérence après une
élection plus léger ce natif aussi raté
elle aurait dû démissionner sa démission
aurait dû être acceptée elle est
maintenu en poste sous respirateur
artificiel parce qu'il faut pas à tordre
et c'est bien normal d'avoir ce qu'elle
est annoncée alors stéphane peut même
question mais avant je voudrais quand
même vous faire écouter le leader
insoumis puisque c'est lui le chef de la
nuque aujourd'hui jean luc mélenchon qui
ne sera plus députés à partir de 2008 ce
soir mais qui a été un peu le guide de
ces de ses camarades à la 110
aujourd'hui écoutés la première demande
c'est madame la première ministre vous
devez venir ici est sollicité leveaux
débutée pour avoir la confiance
et que vous l'aurez pas vous ferez mieux
de nous y préparer et c'est un message
que le président de la république doit
entendre alors expliquez nous ça vous
êtes d'accord avec cette démarche là on
sent que voilà il ya une menace de
censure derrière en tout cas il ya un
vote de confiance qui n'est pas acquis
on va voir ça avec géraldine dans un
instant parce que s'il dit ça c'est
qu'ils vont renverser avec les
oppositions l'annoncé gouvernement pas
du tout c'est que même jean luc
mélenchon il est assez fidèle à l'esprit
des institutions
c'est à dire le gouvernement procède de
la majorité parlementaire ils procèdent
pas du président de la république le
président de la république nomme le
premier ministre mais à partir de ce
qu'est la réalité de l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui l'assemblée
nationale est beaucoup plus
représentatif du peuple français que la
précédente assemblée nationale
on est tous ici je crois a regretté la
force du rassemblement national oui mais
elle est la force du rassemblement
national elle existe dans le pays donc
pas une fois elle se retourne il faut
pas la combattre en la niant ou
de la représentation il faut la
combattre politiquement et il en est de
même pour la gauche et emmanuel macron
qui disait en 2017 avoir été élu par
effraction on est à 35 au fil du temps
que c'est une fausse d'imaginer les
contours d'une négociation possible
maison médicaux mais
les propos de jean-luc et je
n'ai pas du tout des responsabilités
dans l'esprit des institutions et ce
serait à la lettre l'esprit dans les
salles ont failli laissant l'esprit des
institutions je partage le le
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
procède d'un vote majoritaire de
l'assemblée nationale comment pouvez
vous imaginer que la première ministre
reste en place vous donne de ce
gouvernement prétend venir devant
l'assemblée nationale et se dit c'était
un vote de confiance pas franchement
c'est le minimum
la lettre en gros c'est l'artt les
articles 49 alinéa 1 2 3 pour ces
questions
différents types de vote motion de
censure sont des choses différentes
l'obligation de demander un vote de
confiance pour le gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas inscrite
dans la loi mais ça ne veut pas dire que
ce ne soit pas comme vous l'avez
justement des dans l'esprit des
institutions
alors pour bien content de son gardien
arménien et rsa serait quand même la
logique institutionnelle
vernal prend un risque mais elle va elle
sans doute pour solliciter ce vote de
confiance elle est pas sûr qu elle fasse
le ciel elle prive plus expliqué c'est
un vote à la majorité
des suffrages exprimés ça veut dire que
si les voix pour son frère personnes qui
s'abstiennent ce qui me paraît
d'ailleurs un chiffre très possible il
suffira ce 400 il suffit d'avoir 200
pour la faire chuter
c'est pas énorme alors que par exemple
lorsqu'il ya une motion de censure
kettane qui quitte un autre article de
loi reisser avoir l'avoir 289 et là
c'est très compliqué il faudrait tout la
majorité absolue des membres du
parlement de c'est beaucoup plus dur à
faire chuter un jour sur une motion de
censure le gouvernement alors que c'est
un peu plus facile de ne pas lui donner
la confiance mais c'est pas assurés non
plus c'est juste que mémé par ailleurs
si elles ne doivent pas la même
confiance de la
très avenante l'esprit encore une fois
serait qu'elle la sollicitent mais il ya
un risque c'est à elle de mesurer ce
risque patrick vignal c'est
inenvisageable la dent dans la situation
actuelle que la nouvelle premier
ministre ne sollicite pas la confiance
de ce parlement si voilà si nouveau dans
cette situation la meilleure conscience
et s'occuper des français mangent entend
depuis tout à l'heure effectivement le
précédent mandat nous n'avons pas assez
écouté les oppositions c'est vrai mais
on parle qu'un d'avenir aujourd'hui le
président de la république s'est engagé
une nouvelle méthode avec des outils
manche et partis séparément terre depuis
toujours qui disent qu'il faut discuter
avec l'opposition
vous avez chers collègues mais arrête de
parler toujours du passé vous avez un
projet pouvoir d'achat des valeurs
opposées
mais là vous pourriez dire oui mais ça
je rendrai temps d'aimer ça sera tant
pis pour nous si on n'est pas capable de
vous écouter de niro garros est réservé
à
vous écouter que nous allons faire par
exemple tout à l'heure me myriam encadré
de parler de 2 de la loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat d'abord j'attends de voir ce
qu'il ya dans cette loi mais quand on
vous dit des gel du point d'indicé enfin
c'est pas ça le sujet ça fait depuis
2000 12 2010 accepter une année que le
point d'indicé des fonctionnaires n'a
pas évolué donc c'est pas des gel du
point d'indicé notre proposition c'est
10 % de majoration
c'est pareil sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat l'échec les français les
prennent momentanément mais la question
si on veut régler la question du pouvoir
d'achat et revaloriser le travail dans
notre pays il faut traiter la question
des salaires du smic et des bas salaires
par une conférence salariale quinté avec
c'est de savoir si ouvrir sur le côté
gauche ferme la fenêtre du côté droit
parce que la question c'est de savoir
jusqu'où on peut négocier des deux côtés
de l'échiquier politique je vais vous
faire écouter stanislas guérini qui lui
aussi en tant que toujours actuel
président du parti présidentiel a parlé
est ce que chaque mot voilà on essaye de
comprendre ce qu'il ya derrière de
majorité d'intérêt général écoutez je
crois que le président de la république
il est très sincèrement à la recherche
d'une majorité d'intérêt général pour le
pays et c'est de ça dont on a parlé
rechercher l'intérêt du pays
les français par leur vote nous ont
donné une responsabilité accrue qui est
de prouver les voies du compromis au
service du pays au service des
fondamentaux la valorisation du travail
l'accélération de la transition
écologique l'ordre aussi qu'est attendue
de nos concitoyens
j'analyse minal mehlman trois sujets et
la l'ordre on voit bien qu'il s'agit
plutôt de parler à la droite alors
jusqu'où la droite est ce qu'on parle
aussi aux électeurs du rassemblement
national cadets il ya des élus dans
votre camp qui disent on va aussi devoir
chercher des votes des députés à rennes
sur un certain nombre de sujets et à la
transition écologique nous donnerez
votre avis c'est très choquant ça vous
choque ça énormément ce qu'a dit dupont
moretti est ce qu a dit une députée des
hauts-de-seine hier soir en
faisant des appels du pied au
rassemblement national c'est
effectivement très choquant et ça monte
d'ailleurs la vraie la vraie réalité de
la république marc sirot qu'un texte
contribue à boire de vin en commun
emmanuel macron
rêver le tabou de nom de d'avoir un
deuxième tour face à marine le pen il a
tout fait pour faire monter l'extrême
droite dans ce pays et je m'aperçois que
c'était pas seulement un calcul
politicien je m'aperçois que dans les
propres rangs des manuels macron il y a
des gens qui non seulement le font par
calcul politicien mais sont prêts à
avoir des convergences j'ai zappé
j'entends ce que vous dites sur emmanuel
macron qui a tout fait pour faire monter
le rassemblement national extrême droite
au deuxième tour avec son présidentielle
je partage à 100 % mais la démonstration
n'est pas complète emmanuel macron
également fait le même stratagème moment
de l'élection législative en faisant
monter l'extrême gauche avec la nuit
baisse autour de jean luc mélenchon
s'est bien débrouillé tout c est donc
bah écoutez quand vous comparez les
temps de parole sur les différentes
antennes du service public en
particulier vous verrez que la nuque s
occupe 70 parfois 75 voire 80 % tout le
monde est d'accord pour
des gens qui peut pas remplir le caddie
vous pensez que la personne que les
maîtres 50 euros suffisent généralement
doit finir je n'ai pas coupé ça fait dix
ans vous êtes de vous
en faites votre problème disons que les
pages au retur je vais vous dire en fait
votre problème c'est un ressenti
d'amertume pas du tout votre problème
millionnaire les français s'en foutent
aujourd'hui on a un projet de loi vous à
mes propositions à faire la nouba n'a
qu'à le phaser opposition moi j'ai pas
besoin du rafale nationale pour voter à
la masse et gicquel vous dire une chose
je vais vous dire une chose moi je suis
claire
j'ai exactement les mecs des gens de ma
circonscription
moi je suis pour une augmentation de
salaire avec un écart de l'entreprise
mais moi j'ai pas de problème tous les
gens qui vont voter contre parce qu'ils
veulent le chaos et bunge écrit tous mes
jambes je dirais vous voyez ces
personnes ils veulent pas votre
bien-être ont volé sa soeur à témoins
français abandonnés je veux bien qu'on
ne soit pas d'accord tous les deux sur
la retrait de points 2 de 10 mais on va
trouver des points de convergence
tellement mais avons nous excusez moi je
finis nous avons une responsabilité on
va vous faire re venir boire le thé vous
dire merci au revoir je suis d'accord
avec vous mais arrêtez de parler du
passé arrêtez de parler de mépris disant
vous êtes je ne construisait alors j'ai
dit
c'est pas essayer d'avancer un peu dans
ce débat pour construire il faut une
méthode en fait on ne sait pas s'il
s'agit de majorité au cas par cas à
chercher les fameux 44 sur chaque texte
sur une base de négociation on a bien
compris ou si on pourrait parler même de
coalition ce soir l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe chef de la
formation horizon prononce le mot la
coalition ça existe dans beaucoup de
pays je n'ai existe en israël ça existe
en italie ça existe aussi en allemagne
est on capable de faire ce que les
allemands font à chaque élections
légistatives éléments de réponse avec
maria becker
la coalition un gros mot pour les
politiques en france une évidence pour
les allemands une tradition profondément
enracinée dans les moeurs depuis les
années 20 outre-rhin le chancelier
l'équivalent de notre premier ministre
est celui qui réussit à rassembler une
majorité derrière une alliance une fois
les députés élus au bundestag nous
partis que le plus grand nombre de voix
va pouvoir entrer dans des
discussions préliminaires avec d'autres
partis pour voir avec qui elle peut et
peu ils peuvent fermer majorité quand
ils se sont mis d'accord avec qui ça
pourrait se faire ils vont rentrer dans
ce qu'on appelle les négociations du
problème pollution ou la châtoire
maximum de son coin pour son parti
ensuite il rédige ensemble un contrat de
coalition d'une centaine de pages une
feuille de route en quelque sorte qui va
guider le gouvernement et les députés
cette culture du compromis s'explique à
la fois par des raisons
institutionnelles
le vote à la proportionnelle et par la
culture politique allemand si angela
merkel a gouverné 16 ans elle a été
chancelière au sein de différentes
coalitions aux compositions hétéroclites
ce système est il transposable en france
évidemment il faudrait des changements
institutionnelles et constitutionnelles
en paie pas les inventer comme ça et une
structure politique ne s'invente pas un
peu d'un jour à l'autre vous vous partez
de fait la havane l'autre pour ses
propres intérêts et que différents
partenaires n'ont pas des marges de
manoeuvre pour justement obtenir pas
100% de ce qu'ils avaient fixé dans
leurs programmes ou mais peut-être 60 70
ou 500 go car
dans la culture politique française
le compromis est encore perçue comme une
compromission commun accord perdant par
les parties géraldine muhlmann on n'est
pas capable aujourd'hui de former une
coalition en mettant au fond les forces
politiques autour de la table et
négocier on est peut-être capable mais
et ça aurait un certain nombre davantage
mettons qu'il y ait un accord entre l
air om et l air on y aurait des
ministres l air au gouvernement ça veut
dire qu'il y aurait une majorité absolue
à l'assemblée mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'au sénat ça irait très bien parce que
vous auriez les l air avec vous faut
jamais oublier le problème du sénat dans
cette histoire donc ce serait très
confortable sur le plan disons de la
stratégie pour faire passer des lois
pour réformer enfin dans le sens
évidemment de la droite c'est pour ça
que l'américain a assuré lui l'a été il
veut il se voit bien de cette position
négociateurs voire de pivot mots qu'il
aime bien d'ailleurs pourquoi c'est
embêtant à mon avis mais comme mon point
de vue du point de vue de maquereaux
pourquoi parce que nouvelle macro son
récit politique son but là c'est de
rentrer dans l'histoire de laisser une
trace fait quand on est en deuxième
mandat le but ce n'est plus de se faire
élire le but c'est vraiment de laisser
une trace la trace du maquereau nisme
c'est finir avec l air il ya un problème
si beau très franchement macro et les
droites bien plus que de gauche c'est
quand même beaucoup plus clair
maintenant mais de là à signer avec l
air dans un deuxième mandat moi je pense
que le récit politique est problématique
de rester pour l'histoire avec un grand
h ne va pas et que c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles sa solution confortable
sur le plan des accords et des chambres
et ses risques apparaître comme une
force basque réside encore plus
compliqué alors vous pouvez les de
morges et l'excès avec la vierge et pas
un petit bout de l air un petit bout de
lannux mais il faut que vous les prenez
vous coupiez alors que des divergences
et les mêmes soucis au sénat ils votent
les lr contre un texte ne croyez pas que
vous allez avoir quelques l air qui vous
d obéir à leurs copains du sénat et tout
d'un coup se met avec la majorité ça va
être compliqué c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué on peut aussi créer de
nouveaux petits partis exactement comme
à fait noir philippe c'est à dire que il
est parti et il a rejoint clairement la
majorité dont je pense que le il me
semble que l'exécutif en train de se
dire est ce qu'on peut avoir des petits
bouts officiellement avec nous parce que
c'est comme ça qu'il faut et comment on
coupe a qu'un endroit en coupe et qui va
les incarner ces salles suit mais jugez
vous me permettez sur la trace du
maquereau nice puisque c'est intéressant
ce que vous venez de dire moi je pense
mais c'est mon analyse un peu marxiste
de la situation que emmanuel macron
était largement quand il a été élu en
2010 est le produit d'une
bourgeoisie de certains milieux
économiques de ce pays qui considérait
que et la droite et la gauche converti
au libéralisme sous françois hollande
n'allait pas assez vite dans la
conversion de la france à la
mondialisation libérale et que emmanuel
macron allait être par son caractère
disruptif un peu ovni dans le paysage
politique français celui qui allait
s'affranchir de toutes ces pesanteurs
est allé
faire une croix définitive c'est un voeu
explicite du medef faire une croix
définitive sur l'héritage du conseil
national de la résistance et de tous les
acquis sociaux de ce pays donc s'ils
souhaitent éviter vos propos l'un sur
l'otan veut bien peu de marxistes dans
l'analyse
je pense que dans dans cette trajectoire
là qui est la sienne que ce qui les
fonts baptismaux du maquereau nisme et
ben je pense que la trace qui pourrait
laisser de la conversion de la france à
la mondialisation libérale n'est pas
incompatible avec une alliance avec les
voilà le principal intéressé c'était
henri dumont qui représente la
république a de toute façon la porte
elle est fermée de gouverner morte est
fermé à faire la porte est fermée un
pacte de gouvernement ça vient d'être
réaffirmée en bureau politique des
républicains ce soir je vais revenir
d'abord sur la trace parce que emmanuel
macron en 2017 c'était quoi c'était ni
droite ni gauche c'était dépasser les
parties et ça a été dit droite ni gauche
et sa fille ni comment ça finit par et
extrême gauche et extrême droite c'est
particulièrement important je pense de
regarder ça et là trace qu'il a laissée
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à dire le pire chaos de l'histoire
de la vème république j'aime venir
maintenant sur le contrat de
gouvernement ce qu'il faut rajouter
quelque chose analyse pourquoi est ce
que nous refusons un contrat de
gouvernement premièrement parce que nous
ne voulons pas trahir nos électeurs nous
avons dit à nos électeurs que nous
serions dans l'opposition à emmanuel
vous pensez vraiment que c'est le cas
mais écoutez elle salue aujourd'hui
aussi aujourd'hui bien sûr vous êtes en
position de force ils ont joué sur le
fond non mais on est le quatrième vous
seriez absorbé vous passez par là le
quatrième nationale on a 60 un peu plus
de députés
quatrième groupe à l'assemblée vous
croyez vraiment qu'on en position de
force mais non on est allé possession de
corps soient vendus dans un délit mais
bien sûr mais pour une raison qui est
très simple les disait regarde en haut
je termine pour une pomme prune réponse
est une solution extrêmement simple que
se passe-t-il si les républicains
devienne un junior partner de la
république en marche ou du modem ou deux
ensemble eh bien on se retrouve pas à
absorber on se retrouvait ce que vos
portables vous vous retrouvez sur le dos
ou carla voulait en fait tous les
chances pour 2027 pas ça c'est parce
qu'elle sait que c'est à dire que la
seule audible à ça c'est à dire que la
seule alternative dans ce cas à emmanuel
macron pour tous ceux qui ne croient pas
dans la politique menée par emmanuel
macron c'est soit marine le pen soit
jean luc mélenchon et moi pour mon pays
je refuse de laisser le choix aux
françaises et aux français quand c'est
une alternative à +19 expliqué ne pas
gouverner avec mâcon c'est très dur mais
on a fait tous les scénarios on a parlé
des majorités d'idées au cas par cas on
a évoqué la coalition le pacte de
gouvernement c'est non il ya une
dernière idée portée par françois bayrou
s'approcher écoute de l'union nationale
un couple propose union nationale
j'imagine au plus près peut-être avec ou
sans ça c'est a précisé le rassemblement
national en gros toutes les choses sont
libres et six dans le même gouvernement
c'est ça l'union nationale je pense que
ça s'approche plus l'esprit que je
soupçonnais de celui ci voit là d'un
point de vue des manuels macron qui est
de d'avoir envie que les déboutés gros
blocs qui se détache et qui viennent le
rejoindre que c'est plus qu'un récit qui
est plus agréable que celui d'avoir un
fait une coalition avec l air en fin de
deuxième mandat à quoi le problème c'est
que face à vous parents l'implication ça
veut dire qu'il va prendre un bout de
chez les socialistes par exemple qui
vont quitter la nuque sous
exploité dans tiraillements internes à
la nuque et de le coter tiraillements
internes à l air et recrée des partis
qui sont exactement ce que faisait noir
philippe quand il a quitté l air pour
rejouer le rejoint il va créer des
petits bouts autour de lui c'est
peut-être ça et je ne suis pas si jamais
ça que l'organisme a mis dans l union
nationale je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire pierre henri dumont lune et
national écoutez l'union nationale c'est
à dire qu'il faudrait le faire sans
mélenchon et sans le rassemblement la
chaîne c'est-à-dire 150% en réalité des
électeurs si on prend le résultat des
élections présidentielles on voit bien
que c'est anticiper un gouvernement à la
jeunesse de bric et de broc non mais
c'est encore quelque chose c'est quelque
chose qui est de bric et de broc écoutez
cette assemblée gouvernable cette
assemblée gouvernable il faut juste
avoir une culture différente qui est la
culture du compromis la discussion c'est
quelque chose évidemment auquel on n'est
pas habitué parce que ça fait depuis
cinquante-huit qu' il ya un fait
majoritaire qui s'impliquent dans ce
pays et que généralement ce président la
république qui décide où le premier
ministre de cohabitation les trois
compilations nous avons eu est bien là
faudra prendre un peu plus de temps des
remises ou à gérer la pression
collègues cette assemblée est illogique
et en
attendant on va s'arrêter là parce que
quelque chose me dit voilà
ça existait dans notre pays
mais quand jean moulin à fédérer les
réseaux de résistance dont la résistance
communiste la résistance police il a
fédéré en élaborant un programme du
conseil national de la résistance et
c'est de ce programme et on revient d un
gouvernement d union nationale de la
direction en tout cas c'était clair on a
évoqué des hypothèses de brouillard
voilà est toujours là mais peut-être que
les moins épais merci à vous merci pour
vos expertises merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp ce soir on va accueillir
à présent notre grand témoin on la
surnomme la guerrière des insoumis elle
a été élue dès le premier tour et elle
promet d'être une voix forte de
l'opposition on a plein de questions à
poser à sofia chekir ou comme l'exquise
ce portrait signé thibault et locke
regarde si on vous invite sofia chikhi
rousset que vous êtes une des figures de
la nouvelle vague de la nuque qui vient
de déferler sur l'assemblée
une figure centrale même chauffé à
jovial si jean luc mélenchon vous voulez
juste à ses côtés ce matin sur la photo
c'est qu'il estime que la conseillère de
l'ombre que vous avez longtemps été
cheville ouvrière et stratège de la
france insoumise mérite sa place dans la
lumière il faut dire que vous y semblait
à l'aise chez pierrot
comme lors de votre arrivée à
l'assemblée dès la semaine dernière
veste rose et v de la victoire
vous qui avez été élu dès le premier
tour à paris avec 57% des voix wydad
émotions évidemment après j'ai tendance
est très militante politique et donc les
émotions peut-être pour les gardes un
peu pour la sphère privée maîtriser
l'image maîtriser le discours sofia
shigeru c'est votre métier conseiller en
communication votre élection
l'aboutissement d'un long parcours
engagé à 18 ans parti socialiste passé
par toutes les nuances de la gauche
candidate aux législatives dès 2007 vous
rencontrer jean luc mélenchon en 2008 un
tournant pendant une décennie vous serez
celle qui murmure à l'oreille du
candidat jusqu'à finalement faire
entendre votre propre voie à prendre sa
responsabilité
nous sommes le seul choix possible
aujourd'hui sofia chikhi roues dans ce
rôle de stratège on vous dit
l'inspiratrice de bien des coups d'éclat
de jean luc mélenchon depuis une
décennie fruit à la fureur le tumulte et
le fracas en 2017 vous sortez de votre
chapeau du dd hologram marquera les
esprits et les rats se démultiplier le
candidat dans plusieurs villes de france
après la présidentielle cette année là
vous crée même un média le média site
d'actualités et web tv engagés dont vous
prenez la direction pour produire
diffuser ce qu'on fait là actuellement
la suite est plus sombre 2018 sera votre
année noire évincé du média au vos
méthodes sont critiqués vous êtes mis en
cause pour des soupçons de
surfacturation de votre société de
communication votre relation privée avec
jean luc mélenchon est mis sur la place
publique loin d'être abattus vous
répondez à la sulfateuse je ne vais pas
baisser les yeux je ne baisserai pas les
yeux et pour me faire baisser les yeux
il faudra me laisse crever c'est mon
caractère on ne fait pas baisser la tête
je ne suis pas ce genre de femme alors
se fiait chipirons cette femme de
caractère qu'elle députés sera t-elle
vous qui vous affichez si conquérante
quels seront vos combats
bonsoir social chico et bienvenue sur ce
plateau on a vu les archives votre
première bataille législative c'était en
2007 aux côtés du socialiste michel
charzat dans le 20e arrondissement 15
ans après ça y est et ben vous y êtes
vous êtes à l'assemblée nationale quel
sera votre premier combat qu'est ce
qu'elle représente cette élection pour
vous d'abord c'est pas une élection
comme les autres parce que le résultat
n'est pas facile à comprendre j'imagine
que pour beaucoup de français c'est
l'incompréhension totale et c'est une
situation totalement inédite dans la
vème république que la phrase de
mélenchon qui disait si cemac ronces et
de la quatrième république dans la 5e se
vérifie dès le début on est depuis
dimanche soir dans une situation
politique incroyable de blocage
institutionnel de fonctionnement il faut
pas tromper les gens alors en minimisant
la gravité de la situation moi je fais
partie deux des nouveaux députés qui se
disent que comment va fonctionner
l'assemblée nationale dans ces
conditions comment la sincérité
parlementaire d'un exploit personnel
est-ce que c'est l'aboutissement d'un
combat politique
on vous dit voilà une militante farouche
certains vous comparent à une guerrière
vous êtes une dure à cuire vous avez au
fond était dans l' influence pendant une
partie de votre votre carrière et puis
dans la politique est aujourd'hui
l'élection ça ça a quel sens pour vous
je crois que beaucoup de gens du madrés
d'entendre de la nation aujourd'hui
beaucoup de moins de gens ont du mal à
saisir ce qu'est un militant politique
qui est convaincu par ce qu'il fait ce
n'est pas du tout un
comment dire un aboutissement cette
élection pour moi pas du tout je pense
que l'aboutissement sera le jour où nous
gouvernerons nous dirigerons le pays où
nous appliquerons notre programme et
nous changerons la vie des gens donc mon
sort personnel finalement dans dans
cette affaire a très peu d'importance et
moi je ne vis pas ça comme
je ne me sens pas du tout parvenus pour
employer une expression familière et
assez connu vous avez réfléchi à la
députée que vous avez envie d'être je
pense que je serai jamais en quoi vous
allez vous investir s'il y avait un
combat pour marquer cette législature
j'ai réfléchi au travail que je veux
mener à l'assemblée nationale parce que
c'est normal de réfléchir on est élu
pour faire un travail donc c'est vrai
que j'envisage de rejoindre la
commission des affaires économiques et
de travailler notamment sur une
réflexion et des propositions de loi sur
la question de la propriété et notamment
de la propriété collective des biens
communs je crois qu'il est temps de
remettre en question cette question de
la propriété dans notre pays on encense
beaucoup la propriété privée elle est
protégée tant mieux la prostitution la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
protègent la propriété privée c'est très
bien mais nous sommes dans une telle
situation de crise avec l'urgence
climatique l'urgence sociale qu'ils vont
lancer des espaces de vie bien comme
l'était collective donc à cette forme de
propriété collective à des formes de
propriété collective qui sont pas
forcément des nationalisations mais qui
peuvent être et notamment ce que je
souhaite développer des sociétés de que
deux coopératives d'intérêt collectif
qui permettent à plusieurs acteurs dont
des acteurs privés d'intervenir dans ce
type de propriété un exemple concret et
bien très concrètement
dans l'énergie il existe en france une
scic une société qui opère d'intérêt
collectif qui s'appellerait je crois
enercoop ou nrj cops j'ai peur de me
tromper là l'instant mais c'est une
coopérative qui permet de réunir des
partenaires industriels donc privé
investisseurs privés et des partenaires
publics à l'envers dans les
bénéficiaires on verra si si ce projet
qu'on dit si dans ce cadre un peu voilà
confus pour le moment d'un point de vie
politique un aboutissement vous avez dit
tout à l'heure ça au fond ce n'est pas
une affaire personnelle tant que nos
idées ne sont pas au pouvoir j'aurais
l'impression que mon combat ne sera pas
abouti vous allez nous dire c'est le
résultat d'un nul est à la hauteur de
vos espérances comment elle va
fonctionner d'ailleurs cette grande
coalition de gauche de 131 députés hier
la proposition surprise de jean luc
mélenchon de constituer un groupe unique
l assemblée n'a pas trouvé preneur parmi
les partenaires mais pas de quoi
empêcher une arrivée groupée et massive
de l'ensemble de ces insoumis
socialistes et communistes avec le
leader insoumis lui même qui s'est
chargé de la visite nicolas quad ou un
ultime v de la victoire sur les marches
du palais bourbon les nouveaux députés
de la nuque font une entrée remarquée à
l'assemblée nationale soucieux
d'afficher un visage uni est bien décidé
à faire oublier les dissensions d'hier à
propos d'un groupe parlementaire commun
nombreux et qui portent des visions 6,6
convergentes on a hâte de se mettre au
travail on a hâte de retrouver
nos collègues
député insoumis socialistes communistes
on va pouvoir aller les saluer la
immédiatement une photo de famille et
quelques pas de danse plus tard
c'est jean luc mélenchon désormais
député honoraire qui guide ses collègues
dans les travées du palais bourbon et un
jour viendra où il faudra changer
le fondement et ne trouvera un
passage indispensable dans l'hémicycle
et photos souvenirs au perchoir pour la
déjà très populaire rachel kéké
au revoir rachel kéké
alors que moi j'étais allé plus d'une
fois la soutenir sur la lutte des femmes
de chambre de l'hôtel ibis la voir l'un
au perchoir en tant que député cet
effort première séance publique de la
législature mardi prochain à 15 heures
reste à savoir si malgré les désaccords
cette grande coalition va perdurer dont
le thon ou positive voilà 131 députés de
la nuque arrivée groupée ce matin cette
alliance elle est vraiment faite pour
durer c'est ce qu'on souhaite en tout
cas et on fait tout pour on a construit
une culture commune au moment de la
campagne législative
ça s'est très bien passé dans les
circonscriptions avec les différentes
composantes de la nuque et surtout je
crois que le fait qu' hier jean luc
mélenchon est proposé qu on est un
groupe commun à l'assemblée nationale
alors que ce n'était pas prévu dans
l'accord qui manifestement voilà était
un petit peu cavalier pour porte prison
alors l'impression qu'on les mettait un
peu de voyeur fans
répondent il faut savoir à qui on
s'adresse est ce qu'on parle uniquement
à des élus et à des composantes
politiques qui sont des organes
politiques qui pensent que en arrivant à
l'assemblée nationale on constitue son
groupe on a des collaborateurs il ya des
enjeux qui sont pas négligeables un
avantage à avoir un gros pot taurian au
mur il faut pas les négliger mans
financer ou alors est-ce qu'on s'adresse
à au grand nombre au peuple français et
à l'histoire et au moment politique on
est en train de vivre nous on dit il y à
une telle instabilité on est dans une
zone de turbulence politique tel qu'il
faut apporter de la clarté et de la
clarification pour que les gens s'y
retrouvent et et apporter de la
stabilité à l'assemblée si on a un
groupe nuque qui sera un coût conséquent
il est le premier groupe d'opposition
personne ne peut le contester
certainement pas les maquereaux nist qui
aujourd'hui sont juste en train de jouer
à un jeu vicieux pervers dangereux pour
la démocratie qui est celui d'aller
s'allier salé qui élaguent la route
unique ce dossier cette question d'aller
refermer aujourd'hui ou à l'espace fermé
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle se
s'ouvrira parce que je vous le dis
encore j'insiste les choses ne vont pas
se passer comme on a l'habitude qu'elle
se passe on a parlé de ça dans le
premier débat aller chercher construire
des majorités voilà la suite ne va pas
être si simple
donc les quatre groupes qui constituent
la nuque de l'assemblée nationale vont
devoir trouver un fonctionnement qui
compte tenu de ce qu'est l'assemblée
nationale de son règlement à mon avis
terminera par un groupe unique d'accord
les votes on entendait jean luc
mélenchon tout à leur expliquer qu'il
demandait très fermement à la première
ministre elisabeth bornes de demander le
vote de confiance à l'assemblée
nationale faute de quoi il y aurait
motion de censure sauf qu'il n'est plus
député alors là est-ce que c'est pas
l'erreur de jean luc mélenchon d'avoir
laissé son siège avec cette situation
inédite est-ce que c'est par là font
une sorte de manque d'intuition ce qui
allait se passer de ne pas être là alors
qu'il y ait encore on sent qu'il a du
mal à quitter les lieux jean luc
mélenchon a pris une décision qui lui
est personnelle c'est-à-dire celle de ne
pas solliciter un nouveau mandat c'est
quelqu'un qui a justifié ça en disant
j'ai déjà été cette fois parlementaire
il applique ce qu'il prône le
renouvellement de la représentation
nationale
il est très fier aujourd'hui de ce que
nous sommes
le nouveau groupe de sa diversité
sociale de l'entrée dans l'hémicycle de
personnes qu'on n'aurait jamais imaginé
à la scène notamment à celle qui était
alors à à matignon deux agents de l'état
ouvrière agricole un petit jeunes
étudiants précaires on représente la
société entière donc je pense qu'il n'a
aucun regret à avoir et il n'a
d'ailleurs aucun sur la décision qu'il
avait prise de ne pas se représenter je
rappelle que s'il s'était présenté il
aurait été réélu sans difficulté
ce départ choix qu'il a faits qu'a pris
le bruit et la fureur
c'est possible sans mélenchon à
l'assemblée vous nous avez vu vous avait
montré quelques images des députés la
france a soumises et les députés
insoumis ont une particularité c'est que
ils ne sont pas formatés ils ne
correspondent pas à des normes
habituelles
ils ne sont pas
ce ne sont ni des bureaucrates ni des
apparatchiks ni des technocrates ce sont
des gens qui viennent des luttes
diverses et variées donc il s'exprime
comme ils sont et on a toujours dit aux
insoumis soyez ce que vous êtes parce
que ce qui fait que vous êtes
intéressant ce qui fait que vous valait
la peine d'être entendu écouté et de
sincérité bon ben on verra ce que ça
donne oui tout à fait une nouvelle
aventure politique qui commence à
l'assemblée rester avec moi sofia
shigeru c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos a
franchi pour leur parti pris ce soit le
regard de jean ray nibaudeau sur le
front républicain
fanny d'une housse et va nous éclairer
sur le poste le plus convoité du moment
à l'assemblée nationale la présidence de
la commission des finances et puis
réservé il va nous dire comment les
européens nous regarde après la claque
législatives pour emmanuel macron nos a
franchi les voici bonsoir à vous trois
et merci d'être là la politique jeu rémi
baudot le fait marquant on le dit on le
répète c'est aussi social shigeru
l'entrée en force de 89 députés
rassemblement national à l'assemblée cet
historique signe pour vous que le front
républicain est mort et enterré ou pas
alors on ne sait pas s'il est mort mais
en tout cas il n'a pas fonctionné il
faut regarder la manière dont les
électeurs se sont comportés entre les
deux tours le tout sauf mélenchon à
fonctionner le tout sauf macron aussi le
corollaire c'est que le vote et rennes
en a été dopée concrètement quand les
candidats étaient absents quand leur
candidat était absent du second tour les
électeurs de la nuque d'ensemble et de l
air se sont majoritairement abstenus un
refus de choisir qui a mécaniquement
fait remonter les candidats et rennes
plus frappant encore quand il y avait
des matches nuls et rennes les électeurs
ensemble aux veaux trn à 12% je
reformule ça veut dire que 12% des
électeurs macro nist ont voté pour le
rassemblement national
clairement le barrage républicain a cédé
comment vous expliquez ça une addition
de plusieurs facteurs certains facteurs
dont on parle largement ici une
banalisation du rassemblement national
mais il ya aussi un discours un peu
ambigu de la part de la majorité
présidentielle ces dernières semaines un
flop - après le premier tour sur les dg
sud et les législatives sur la question
des consignes de votes de la part de la
macro ni fallait-il faire barrage au fn
en soutenant la nuque le récit n'était
pas très clair à cornet risée les deux
autres blocs politiques comme deux
extrêmes la macro ni le bloc désormais
central de notre vie politique c'est un
peu coincé même et ses ambiguïtés sur
les consignes de vote alors c'est plus
clair c'est terminé ou pas alors oui
mais en fait pas du tout la nouvelle
configuration politique avec une faible
majorité pour la macro n'y pousse à
rechercher évidemment des compromis à
tout prix hier soir sur france 5 céline
calvaise la députée lrm réélu affirmé je
cite quand on a besoin d'avoir une
majorité et si c'est bon pour les
français on va aller chercher les voix
du rassemblement national
chez les sondés un ministre tout à
l'heure qui m'a dit débile et
inacceptables inacceptables ok sauf que
ce matin je suis passé aux quatre
colonnes ici dans cet humble
institutions de l'assemblée nationale et
j ai vu des députés de la majorité
préféré un député est reine à la tête de
la commission des finances plutôt qu'un
député et la fille il ya manifestement
toujours de meilleures raisons de se
tourner vers la droite de la droite que
vers la gauche de la gauche à dire qu'il
est possible de travailler avec le r est
la macro ni rend inaudible son combat
contre l'extrême droite qui est
normalement une partie de son adn et il
offre aussi un boulevard à marine le pen
qui n'attend qu'une chose que son parti
soit normalisée pour être aujourd'hui un
partenaire comme un autre et peut-être
demain un candidat comme un autre à la
présidentielle une réaction sofia chic
là bas on est dans une situation
extrêmement inquiétante d'abord il faut
constater et reconnaître la trahison des
manuels macro et des maquereaux nist je
vous rappelle qu'il a été élu avec un
certain nombre de voix de la gauche pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite il l'a
oublié mais rappelons lui quand même il
ya deux mois il nous demandait de voter
pour lui pour être élu président de la
république
là deux mois après ils gardent le
silence sur ce sujet et il attend de
voir comment les choses se passent donc
il tente et manon attendant c'est tout à
fait son genre je pense que j'ai compris
d'opinion fera de jouer sur deux l'a
produite et il a déjà permis que
l'extrême droite soit aussi hot et soit
à ce point présente à l'assemblée moi je
crains qu'à l'avenir est vraiment c'est
une alerte qu'il faut lancer aux
citoyens français à l'avenir macro est
tout à fait capable de les normaliser à
tel point que dans un an dans deux ans
je ne sais pas combien de temps cette
législature va durer le pouvoir revienne
à l'extrême droite donc nous on a une
responsabilité
combien de temps deux ans vous pensez
qu'il ira pas au bout de son mandat je
pense que la visualisation elles m'ont
compliqué lioret
la pétition nationale gouvernable marine
le pen à matignon sept jeux possibles
macro et les maquereaux nice dans leur
attitude dangereuse
calculatrice manipulatrice sont en train
d'organiser tout le terreau de préparer
le terreau à l'extrême droite voilà on
risque d'avoir l'extrême droite au
pouvoir s'il continue de cette façon là
il faut clarifier les choses il faut
vraiment qu'on prenne conscience de la
gravité de la situation les maquereaux
nist joue à un jeu extrêmement dangereux
il faut qu'ils arrêtent il faut qu
emmanuel macron interviennent on verra
ce que ce qu'il en sera dans les jours
qui viennent la chronique de fanny
guaino c'est va aussi vous intéressez
sophistiqué roues parce que on va parler
du poste convoité le plus convoité du
moment la présidence de la commission
des finances que la france insoumise et
la nuque pardonnez-moi à l'ensemble de
la collection de gauche convoite
largement pourquoi tout le monde veut ce
poste bien parce que c'est un poste
discret mais qui est stratégique parce
qu'il ya des preuves relatives très
importante quand on est président de la
commission des finances on examine les
textes budgétaires et notamment le
premier d'entre eux c'est à dire le
projet de loi de finances on participe
au contrôle du budget par exemple on
peut saisir l'autorité de la concurrence
et puis s'y ajoute un pouvoir
d'investigation c'est à dire que le
président de cette commission peut avoir
accès en toute légalité
à n'importe quel dossier fiscal d'un
citoyen ou d'une entreprise on lève
lever le secret fiscal évidemment il n'a
pas vocation à dévoiler cette
déclaration fiscale notamment à la
presse mais c'est un contrôle très
important un contrôle aussi de l'action
du gouvernement et allez dans n'importe
quelle administration demandé un
document et c'est un droit de regard qui
est extrêmement fort alors on sait que
c'est une tradition un usage mais c'est
quand même dans le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas dans la
constitution ce poste revient à
l'opposition oui un membre de
l'opposition alors pas forcément le
premier groupe d'opposition c'est là où
il y as bataille ce président est élu
par les députés qui siègent dans cette
commission des finances alors de fait
légitimement marine le pen peut le
demander c'est ce qu'elle a fait elle
réclame la présidence de cette
commission et la nuque le réclame
également
jusqu alors la majorité ne prenait pas
part au vote mais là aussi c'est une
tolérance ça se faisait par consensus
mais ça pourrait changer parce que eh
bien dans la macro nyon n'a pas très
envie de voir un membre ni la nuque des
les filles ni de france internationale
accédant à ce poste des publicains avoir
des les républicains peuvent aussi le
demander mais pour eux comme ils n'ont
pas la majorité il faudra qu'ils aient
des soutiens qui il ya déjà tout le
monde est dans les starting blocks et la
compétition est lancée chez vous
notamment au sein de la nubie il ya
plusieurs noms qui circulent eric
coquerel qu'a dit qu'ils étaient
intéressés mais sa collègue aussi
économiste aurélie trouvé au ps valérie
rabault que l'on connaît parce qu'elle
est et rapporteuse du budget donc elle
connaît ses sujets elle a dit ne pas
s'interdire de regarder de ce côté du
côté du rassemblement national il ya un
petit peu moins de monde jean philippe
tanguy pourrait être un des êtres le
président celui qui serait présentée
parce que c'est le concepteur du
programme économique de marine le pen
alors c'est un poste très techniques
qu'il faut quand même avoir quelques
connaissances de finances publiques mais
vous l'aurez compris c'est aussi un
poste extrêmement politique le vote doit
avoir lieu le 30 juin c'est aussi pour
ça que jean luc mélenchon est un groupe
unique pour être le premier à laure
noualhat rialland prix
là tous les groupes peuvent se sont mis
d'accord de toute façon sur le fait qu
on présenterait un seul candidat à la
présidence de la commission des finances
a fait partie de l'accord n'avait qui
sera non je ne sais pas encore même si
je le savais je le dirai pas tant que
aller à la ronde on
allait il serait logique que le groupe
les quatre groupes qui forment la nuque
sont majoritaires normand c'est à eux de
voter et de désigner puisqu'on compte
sur l'abstention habituel ce serait pas
une nouveauté des macros nist dans sa
mission
le grand bazar parlementaire vu de
l'étranger qu'est ce que ça donne on ad
on a des médias qui parlent de ce qui
nous est arrivé
un nouveau mode de gouvernement -
présidentielle comment on voit des
choses vues d'europe il y à hofu ont vu
d'europe il ya deux sortes d'opinions
alors il ya ceux qui croient qu'un grand
bouleversement démocratique et ils sont
félicite a frappé la france dimanche
alors c'est par exemple le cas du
quotidien allemand berliner morgenpost
pour qui le président français aura
désormais besoin de partenaire pour
faire passer des lois et il ajoute comme
chez nous et ailleurs comme en allemagne
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
outre-rhin on sait que c'est une
habitude alors il y associe qui croient
en europe au début de la fin du second
mandat présidentiel des manèges macron
j'ai trouvé ce titre dans un quotidien
croate traduit en anglais c'est fait
macron a perdu la confiance des
électeurs il ne le laisseront plus ils
les électeurs ne le laisseront plus
continuer à diriger le pays sans aucune
limite alors adieu donc mâcon tout
puissant c'est fini sauf que si cette
révolution intéresse les observateurs
européens les médias elle fait moins la
sphère des gouvernements surtout ceux
qui reconnaissent au président français
son leadership européen vous savez qu'il
termine le 30 juin la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne et nous
sommes ne l'oublions pas la veille deux
sommets cruciaux puisque les 27 pays
membres de l'ue eux se retrouvent à
bruxelles ce jeudi et ce vendredi le g7
va se réunir en allemagne ce week-end
les 30 pays de l'otan l'alliance
atlantique vont se retrouver à madrid
les 29 et 30 juin alors ça alimente
quand même l'inquiétude del mundo le
quotidien conservateur espagnol on
attend quand même de l'elysée écrit-il
que macron façon encore preuve de
leadership dans une union européenne de
plus en plus ébranlée par des défis
comme celui de la russie jugé son
éditorialiste et la stabilité française
inquiète sur le fond c'est exactement ça
parce que l'instabilité c'est quelque
chose qui en général n'est pas associé à
la france sur le plan politique parce
que pour les voisins européens alors
c'est peut-être normal que le chef de
l'état soit bousculée mise en minorité à
l'assemblée nationale les pays
parlementaires savent ce que c'est
qu'une négociations entre partis mais il
le trouve inquiétant parce qu'il redoute
cet affaiblissement et notamment parce
qu'il y a ceux d'août il faut bien le
dire en europe sur les principes aux
opposants emmanuel macron que ce soit
jean luc mélenchon marine le pen à
propos de la russie je n'ai pas besoin
d'y revenir la france on oublie souvent
au sein de l'union européenne elle
al'avantage de son système centralisé en
général ce que décide son président et
bien c'est appliquer s'est exécuté donc
effectivement bazar parlementaire ça
fait peur mais aussi mauvais souvenir
des périodes de cohabitation des
ambiguïtés compliqué rappelez-vous le
rwanda à la tragédie drogba se passe
quand même en période de cohabitation
mitterrand balladur
le traité européen de nice qui a été
extrêmement difficile à arracher c'était
la cohabitation entre jacques chirac et
lionel jospin et puis il y a toujours
cette méfiance quand les français
commencent à se fâcher ça peut se
terminer en révolution c'est pierrot le
mot de la fin c'est on sait pas si le
mot crise de régime et est trop fort ou
pas mais en tout cas dans une crise
politique majeure au brussels nous
regarde les marchés nous regarde il
devrait y avoir des conseils qu'on ne
faut pas découvrir la crise démocratique
en france elle n'est pas nouvelle moi je
fais partie des gens qui pensent que le
référendum de 2005 justement sur le
traité constitutionnel européen qui a
été bafoué la décision populaire a été
bafouée trois ans après vous en rappeler
en 2008 quand nicolas sarkozy a ratifié
le traité de lisbonne si je ne dis pas
de bêtises
c'était déjà c'était l'ouverture de la
crise démocratique qu'on a vu exploser
avec les gilet jaune notamment et les
revendications démocratiques
institutionnels n'ont pas cessé depuis
compris en période de qu'ovide donc la
crise démocratique en france elle est
lancinante la fin de régime dont la fin
de la 5ème république est là et non
défend la 6ème à voile à passer à autre
chose et pour renouveler tout cela merci
à vous merci de nous avoir accompagnés
sur s&p dans cette émission csu et merci
à vous les affranchis a très vite fin de
cette émission tout de suite votre
soirée documentaire un film inédit ce
soir ukraine des photographes dans la
guerre aux belles soirées allemand
c